hey 42 here 35% of the people who use
personal ads for dating are already
married
welcome to Rick the Vatican City is the
only place in the world where cash
machines offer instructions in Latin to
escape the grip of a crocodile's jaws
put your funds into its eyeballs it will
let you go instantly in France of five
year old child can buy an alcoholic
drink in a bar it takes a photon 200,000
years to travel from the core of the Sun
to its surface then just a little over
eight minutes to travel from the Sun
surface to your eyeball there is a trash
vortex in the Pacific Ocean known as the
Great Pacific Garbage Patch that is
roughly the size of Texas
the average person falls asleep in seven
minutes the national anthem of greece
has a 158 verses no one in greece has
memorized the entire anthem to date
wikipedia has taken about a hundred
million man-hours to create which is
actually not a lot when you consider
that people in the US alone spend about
1.5 billion man-hours every month
watching TV advertisements a rat can
last longer without water than a camel
1/5 of the world's doctors are Russian
there are 293 ways to make change out of
$1 there are only 4 words in the English
language which end in do us tremendous
horrendous stupendous and hazardous if
you view a bald eagle at a zoo you are
looking at the American symbol of
freedom in captivity if you were to be
paid $500 in pennies you would actually
have enough metal to be melted down and
sold for over a thousand dollars thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2